I tried to film a get ready with me while I was like
talking to the camera I couldn't concentrate
I didn't know what I was putting on my face and trying to say at the same time
does anybody else have that problem
or is it just me anywho
last week I chatted a little about how I became a homeschool mom
but I wanted to talk a little about what I did in between
I had my oldest daughter in my third year of teaching
at the beginning of the school year
I had her in August and then I took six weeks of Matern leave
which not enough and then I went back and finish out the school year
so that entire year the first year of her life
I was a working mom and if you know anything about being a teacher
it is not a 40 hour week job
you are doing after school stuff
you are doing things on the weekends prepping
planning all things
I was so miserable so at the end of the year
I quit and I was just a stay at home mom until I had my second
and they are two years apart
and then when my son was like four months old
I started teaching from home
and I taught English to students in China
so my hours were awful
but we were just in this place financially where we just could not get ahead
we were living paycheck to paycheck
my husband was working a hundred plus hours and it just didn't feel good
so I start working from home
I did that for two years and we changed our lifestyle
moved into an RV and that I became just a stay home mom again
and then when my daughter was in pre K
her teacher went on maternity leave and I said for her
and then I became a preschool teacher for two years until my daughter started
so over the years I have been a working mom
I have been a stay at home mom
a work from home mom and now homeschool mom
and I can honestly say from all of those experiences
this is by far the most taxing and the hardest thing I have ever done in my life
but also the most rewarding